[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT SULLIVAN: Good
morning, and welcome
to the build reactive
apps with Flutter session.
My name is Matt Sullivan.
FILIP HRACEK: And my
name Filip Hracek,
and we're both developer
advocates on the Flutter team.
MATT SULLIVAN: So let's kick
off with looking at how to build
reactive apps on Flutter.
Flutter lets you
build beautiful apps.
It gives you the
ability to create
fluid and customized,
sophisticated UIs There's
a few examples up
here just to show
you the different
range and types
of apps that you can
build with Flutter.
At the heart of Flutter's UI
is a powerful, reactive model.
I'm going to give you the 30
second summary of how it works,
and then we're going to
deep dive into things.
Firstly, in Flutter, all
UI components are widgets.
As you can see here, we have
a widget that's a button.
Secondly, you take these widgets
and you compose them together
to create complex UIs.
So we're going to
refer repeatedly
to what we call the widget
tree, and that's literally how
we're building these together.
Thirdly, and
importantly, Flutter
manages the relationship
between state and UI,
and it only rebuilds
those widgets when
their state changes,
and it relieves you
of having to do that task.
So, for example, here, when we
call setState() on the greeting
widget, it's going to
automatically redraw itself.
And that's great and wonderful,
but building complex apps
is never easy.
Apps typically have
thousands of UI components,
but more importantly, they
have very complicated,
and potentially
sophisticated state
that's reacting with those
UI components asynchronously
at different times in your app.
The good news is that
Flutter provides you
with all the tools necessary,
not only to build UI,
but also to handle complex
data flow and state
in your app that
fits in elegantly
well with Flutter's reactive
model for building UIs.
Now, Flutter's UI
patterns are well-known
and well-documented-- you can
check them out on flutter.io--
but Flutter's reactive
strategies for handling state
are not so well-known.
So we're going to focus
the talk on how to do that.
We're going to take
you on a journey.
Firstly, we're going to look
at the foundations of Flutter
and state to show you the
basis of how things work.
What we're going
to do then is we're
going to explore how
state and the widget tree
can be married together.
And thirdly, we're
going to look at how
you can use Flutter
streams to elegantly manage
state in your app.
Now, at each of these, we're
going to do some live coding--
and clearly, nothing
is not going to run.
But we're going to
do some live coding,
and these examples will
be relatively simple.
But we want you to
keep in mind how
these can be scaled out to more
complex state, and larger apps.
And importantly, the
examples you'll see here
have been derived from
production apps built
with Flutter, both by
Google and by other parties.
So let's dive in and look at
managing state in the simplest
app we can think of, which
is the incrementor app, which
is what you get out of the box
when you do Flutter create.
Flutter's reactive model
is straightforward for UI
and state, but it's
a little different
to how things are handled
with Android and iOS.
So we're going to dive in
by looking at this app,
and we're going to look at a
common pitfall that typically
catches people out
when they initially
start thinking about
reactive systems in general.
Filip.
FILIP HRACEK: All right.
So this is a very
exciting moment for me,
because I'm going to
break an app on stage
at IO, which, if
you think about it,
that's exactly the opposite
of what you normally
want to do on stage.
Well, this is in the name
of learning and science,
so it's OK.
So if you're not
familiar with this app,
this app is very exciting.
It shows you a number, and it
lets you increment that number.
The important parts are there
is the counter variable,
there's the build method
that creates the UI.
Here is the widget which
actually shows that number--
number four, right now.
And here's the
floating action button,
which is this guy
over here, which
lets you change that variable.
Now, imagine that this
was a much bigger app,
and we wanted to put a
little more structure to it.
We would do that,
often, by extracting
parts of the build method
into its own widget.
So I'm going to do just that.
I'm going to take this out,
create a new widget called
incrementor, and I'm just going
to paste the code over here.
We're not done.
As you can see, there's red
squiggly lines over there,
which means we have a problem.
And the problem is that
we cannot actually access
the counter variable from here,
because we're in this class,
while the counter
variable is in this class.
There are many ways
to solve this problem,
but I have something
very special in mind.
I'm just going to make the
viable global, because I can.
MATT SULLIVAN: So there
you have it folks.
To handle state in Flutter,
you make everything global,
and your app is good.
Yeah-- is that what
we're telling people?
[CHUCKLES]
FILIP HRACEK: No.
Actually, we're trying
to make the point here--
we're trying to break
this app, so please don't
make your variables global.
And we're going to fix this in
two minutes, so stay with us.
We fixed the squiggly lines, so
let's see if this app actually
works, now.
It doesn't.
Now, why is that?
We can add a thing here to see
if the counter variable has
actually changed.
And we see that it
has-- it is now at 12.
But the user doesn't see it.
Why is that?
Well, the reason is that we're
calling setState() in the wrong
widget.
We're breaking the contract
of set state, which
is that you call set state
when you are changing
the state of the widget.
We're not changing the state
of the floating action button
here, we're changing the
state of the widget above it.
And that way, Flutter
doesn't know--
Flutter tries to rebuild
that floating action button,
but that doesn't do anything
with our text over here.
So I'm going to fix it now.
MATT SULLIVAN:
What we need to do
is we need to move set state
into the appropriate widget
where we want to show the
change, or the mutation,
of the state.
So Filip is going to move it
back into the home page widget.
And thankfully, we no longer
have any more global state.
Wonderful.
What we're going to
do then is-- what
we need to do is we need
to be able to pass down
a reference to that function so
it can be called by its child
widget.
So we're basically going to
update the incrementor widget,
we're going to pass
through the function
through the constructor.
And then, what this
is basically giving
is the classic callback
method of being
able to call the function
in the parent widget.
And that should
probably just work.
FILIP HRACEK: And it works.
Awesome.
All right.
Back to slides, please.
So that was great, and it
was pretty easy to fix.
But you can imagine
that if you have
a much larger app with
a lot more widgets,
this could be a problem.
Let's imagine that you
need state over here,
and you have state
somewhere over here.
And now, what you need to do
is, if you follow that pattern
that I just showed you, you
need to pass down the state
down the widget tree.
And that means that all the
widgets that are in that path
need to know about the state,
even though they don't really
care.
And that breaks reuse, it
breaks separation of concerns,
and it also, potentially,
makes the app
rebuild a much larger
portion of the state--
of the UI than you would want.
You only want the leaf
nodes to be rebuilt.
So I've hopefully highlighted
two problems here, or two
challenges.
First, how do I access state
that doesn't necessarily
live in the widget where
I need it, and second,
how do I notify other widgets
that they should rebuild?
Again, I'm going to
score this pattern
that I just showed you with
thumbs down on both accounts,
because while it is easy in
a simple app, in a big app,
it gets more complicated.
And I think we have
a better option here.
MATT SULLIVAN: So let's look
at how we can handle state,
and the concept of passing
state up and down the widget
tree without having to expose
it to all the widgets in between
that don't need to use it.
Flutter has, out
of the box, what
is called an InheritedWidget.
And what an inherited widget
does is it holds state,
and it allows you to propagate
that state efficiently
down the widget tree, and
it will rebuild that widget
tree when that state is
mutated, or that state changes.
So that sounds promising--
that might help us solve this.
What is this going to look like?
Well, basically you have
an InheritedWidget--
we've put it in here.
And as opposed to having to
pass down references to it,
we can use the
build context in any
of the build methods to get an
access to the instance of that
state and use it directly
within our widgets themselves.
So what does that
look like in code?
Here, I have my really cleverly
named MyInheritedWidget,
which extends InheritedWidget,
and in here, you
can see that I have
placed some state.
Perfect.
How do I access that?
Well, I can access
it by, firstly,
placing my InheritedWidget into
my tree, giving it some state,
and then building the
widget tree beneath it.
And then, after
that, I can access it
by simply using
the build context
to get a reference
to that widget,
and then I can access the state.
So that sounds promising.
Well, sure-- now I can access
state anywhere in the tree,
and keep the rest
of my code dry.
My tree, at a
coarse grain level,
does rebuild my state
changes, so that's OK.
But, as you noticed,
my state was final.
That's not very
helpful if you actually
want to mutate your state.
Now, it's not hard to layer in
mutation with InheritedWidget--
it's a bit of boilerplate.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to look at a library
called ScopedModel.
And ScopedModel is
an external package.
It's built on top
of InheritedWidget,
and importantly, it
gives us the access,
it gives us a more
fine-grained way
of rebuilding parts of
our tree, and it allows
us to mutate state, as well.
So looking at code
real quick, ScopedModel
equates to my InheritedWidget.
And we have what's called
a descendent, which
gives us access to the state.
I'm showing all this
stuff on slides--
I want to show it in real
code to show you it working.
But I don't want to show it
to you in the incrementor app
because that's pretty simple.
So Filip and I knocked up
a shopping cart example.
And what that has is it
has three areas where
you need to handle your state.
We've got a cart page which
shows the list of items,
we have a cart button which
shows the number of items
in the cart, and we
have a grid of products,
where each product is tappable,
and should add something
to the cart.
So let's jump over to my
laptop, and take a look at this.
Here, we have the app,
which is already running.
You can see I have
a grid of products.
And at the moment, it's
just showing a snack bar
at the bottom.
We have my cart button, which
is hard-coded to show zero,
and we have a cart page, which
currently is showing empty.
There is no state anywhere
in here at the moment.
These are all
stateless widgets--
this does nothing
except look pretty--
if you consider
this to be pretty.
We're not designers,
but there you go.
What do we need to do?
First, we need to
define our model.
So I have created cart model.
It extends model,
and what it does
is it simply has a cart object
which is holding our state.
We have three different ways
of interacting with this.
We've got a getter to pull
down the list of cart items,
we have item count
which gives us
the number of items in the cart.
And, strangely enough, we have
an add method, or function,
which allows us to place
a product in the cart.
Now, notice here, when I
mutate or change my state,
I'm explicitly calling
notify listeners.
And the way ScopedModel
works is that whenever
you have a descendent widget,
they are observing your state--
they are listening for changes.
And, when our state changes, we
simply call notify listeners,
and all of those
descendent widgets
will be notified that state has
changed, and they will rebuild.
So the whole tree is
not being rebuilt,
only those widgets that
are listening to it,
and the things below them
will be rebuilt. Perfect.
So let's see how I
can use that model
to inject some state to my app.
What I'm going to
do is I'm simply
going to place my state at
the topmost level of my app
for ease to begin with.
What I'm going to
do is I am going
to wrap this in a
new widget, and it
is going to be a ScopedModel.
And, as we can see
here, ScopedModel
takes a model and a child.
So we can keep the subtree as a
child, and I can place a model.
And I'm going to create a
new instance of cart model.
So now I have state existing
at the top of my tree.
Great.
I need to access that
state, so how do I do it?
Let's go down and take
a look at our button.
And here's our button, and
you can see at the moment,
it's hard-coded to show zero.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to follow
the same type of pattern--
I'm going to wrap
this in a new widget.
And, this time, I'm going
to use a descendant widget.
I'm going to type it so it knows
what type of model to look for.
And this doesn't
take a child, it
takes a builder, which will
provide me with the model.
So I'm going to change
my child to builder--
and this is a function.
I need the build context because
that's how InheritedWidget
gets a reference to it.
We have an optional child
widget I'm not going to use,
and we're going to have a model.
So what can I do now?
I should be able to simply
do model dot item count.
Perfect.
We got to do one more
thing to get this to work--
we've got to add some products.
I'm going to do
this super quick.
Here, we have our grid, here,
we have our individual products.
And, again, I'm going to
follow the same pattern--
I'm going to wrap this
in a descendant widget.
I'm going to type it--
and I'm going to
do that properly.
And then, again, I'm going
to change this to a builder,
make this a function, take
my context and my model.
And so, now, what
we can do in here
is-- we've got all
of this snack bar
code, which I can get rid of.
And I should be able
to do model dot add--
and we have a product.
This is all hot reloaded--
I've placed state in there.
I don't have to restart
my app, fingers crossed.
And we'll see if this works.
There we go.
So we've gone from
stateless to stateful.
I haven't changed the
structure of my app.
All I've done is I've layered
in a few extra widgets.
And with the way that
this app is built,
this has worked really nicely.
FILIP HRACEK: This is
nice Matt, but didn't you
say that whenever you
call notify listeners,
you will rebuild the things
below the descendants?
Which means that we are
now rebuilding the product
squares every time you click.
MATT SULLIVAN: So, as
we pointed out before,
notify listeners notifies
all the descendants.
So we're rebuilding this
button, but we're also
rebuilding all of these
products, which is bad.
So why don't we fix
that real quick.
Because ScopedModel descendant
has a rebuild unchanged flag--
and I can set that to false.
And so you shouldn't
see any difference here.
What's happening now
is these products
squares are not being rebuilt.
I already implemented a
descendant for the cart page,
because you don't need to see
me type this a third time,
but it's exactly the
same model there.
So let's jump back
to the slides.
Thank you.
So what does that get us?
Accessing state-- we can access
state arbitrarily down the tree
without having to mess with
our intermediate widgets.
We have a reasonably
elegant means
of notifying our widgets now
by our descendants observing
for state change,
and then rebuilding
when that state changes.
Now, minimal rebuild-- I'm
going to give a thumbs down,
and that's because I had
to, a, be reminded by Filip,
because I constantly forgot
every time we rehearsed this
to do this--
that we had to not
rebuild that part.
There's a cognitive load at
that point for the developers.
You need to work out
should this rebuild,
shouldn't this rebuild,
what's going to happen?
And, when you
evolve your app, you
have this additional level of
needing to worry about this.
So I don't think
this is great, and I
think we probably
need to come up
with a better solution to that.
Funnily enough, we're now going
to look at Flutter support
for streams.
How streams can be built to fit
in with Flutter's UI reactive
model, and how they can
solve this very problem.
FILIP HRACEK: Thank you.
So let's talk about streams.
If you are more familiar
with the term Observables,
they are very closely related.
And, for the
purposes of our talk,
they are basically
interchangeable.
So if you think about
application development,
streams are everywhere.
Every user input is a stream
of asynchronous events.
Every interaction with
the underlying system
is a stream of
asynchronous events.
Every interaction-- obviously,
with the outside world through
the network--
is a stream of
asynchronous events.
And crucially, if
you think about it,
all your updates to the UI is a
stream of asynchronous events.
So people who are
familiar with ReactiveX
and reactive programming,
in general, probably
know where I'm going with this.
But suffice to
say, it makes sense
to think about UI
programming as managing
stream of asynchronous events.
The good news is Dart has really
good support for streams--
it has had that for a long time.
Dart Streams have all the
usual bells and whistles
that you would expect, like
stream transforming, mapping,
folding, and so on.
And Dart even has language
level support for streams,
like asynchronous generators,
the yield keyword, or wait for.
So we have this concept
of streams in Dart,
and it is used throughout
the Dart ecosystem.
And then we have this concept
of reactive extensions
and reactive programming.
On top of that,
there is a package
called our rxdart, which builds
the reactive extensions on top
of the inherent streams in Dart.
So that's really great.
How does that fit into Flutter?
Well, Flutter has
this widget called
StreamBuilder, which is exactly
what you would think it is.
It is a widget that takes
a stream as an input,
and a builder method that
will rebuild every time there
is a new value in the stream.
Any time you have
a stream, like when
you're subscribing to
a FirebaseDatabase,
you can just use StreamBuilder
to rebuild your UI.
So that is already pretty cool.
But wouldn't it be
even more awesome
if we had some kind of
architectural pattern
to build our apps?
So imagine that
you have a big app,
and it has some widgets
that take user input,
so they have streams of
asynchronous events coming
from the user.
And then you have
other widgets that
can be anywhere
else in the widget
tree that try to update whenever
there is a state change.
Now, you cannot just simply
link those two together--
you need something in between,
and we'll call that business
logic, for now.
You need to stream the
events from the widgets that
have buttons and inputs
to the business logic.
Then, their magic happens,
and the business logic
publishes streams
of data changes
to widgets that are
interested in it.
And this can then rebuild.
Crucially, you're
publishing separate streams,
so the other widget could be
interested in a completely
different aspect of your
data, and it will just
subscribe to that stream.
It won't rebuild
any time there's
any change to your model--
it will only rebuild
when there is
a change to that specific
aspect of the model.
Let's have a closer look.
We have streams as inputs,
and streams as outputs.
How would that look in Dart?
Well, we would
have an object that
has Sinks of events as inputs.
Sinks is the input of a
stream-- you put things into it,
and then you can listen
to it on the other hand.
And then there is a
stream of data as output.
Pretty simple.
Now, in our example
with a shopping app,
the simplest possible
cart would be
to have a single product called
addition, to which you would
just shove your products into.
And then it would have
a stream of integers,
called itemCount, which
would update every time
the item count changes.
Internally at Google, we
call these business logic
components, so that
is bloc for short.
Let's switch to the computer.
And I'm going to
implement it real quick.
So this would be my computer.
Yes, I have the same app--
it doesn't change-- it
doesn't currently work.
And we'll need to
implement this pattern.
So I already have
a cart provider
that uses InheritedWidget
so that I can access cart--
this object from
anywhere in my tree.
And, as you can see, I'm
creating this object here,
and then I'm accessing it in
different parts of my app.
But I'm not doing
anything with it, yet.
Also, if you look at the
object now, or the component,
it is pretty empty-- it only
has the underlying model.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to first implement
the Sink of products--
the streaming input.
I'm going to very
quickly code it up,
and then I'm going to
tell you what it does.
So it's going to be a Sink
of products called addition.
This is that input stream that
you can access externally.
And then this is backed
by a stream controller
called additionController.
StreamController is just a basic
class in the stream library
in Dart-- the core library.
And that helps us listen
to the stream of things
that are coming from outside.
Now, how would you
use it in your app?
You would just go to
the product squares,
and wherever you are trying
to add the streams of events,
you would just say cart bloc--
the Sink.
And then we want to
add to the Sink--
in this case, we want
to add the products.
Coming back, we want to
also code the output, which
is a stream of itemCount.
Let me just quickly do that--
itemCount is a stream of int.
And it is backed by
something that you
might know, BehaviorSubject.
BehaviorSubject is
coming from ReactiveX,
and it is a different
kind of stream controller
that has memory of
its latest value.
So, whenever you listen
to it, it will immediately
give you that latest value.
This is in contrast to
normal stream controllers,
or streams, where,
when you listen to it,
you will have to wait
until the value changes.
That could be sometime
in the future.
In our case, we want to
always have the latest value--
the moment that we
listen to a stream.
Now, how would we use that?
Well, now we get to use
the StreamBuilder class.
So we have the
cart button here--
we want it to listen to
changes to the itemCount.
I'm going to wrap it with a
StreamBuilder of integers.
It's going to listen to
the itemCount stream.
The initial data is
going to be zero.
And then, in here, I can
just access the snapshot
of the data, which will
always be the latest
value of the itemCount.
So we have this.
Now, all we need to do is to
merge the streams together,
so that's what I'm
going to do just now.
MATT SULLIVAN:
This is where Filip
will make the magic
happen behind the scenes,
because we've got a bunch
of products coming inbound.
And what we need
to do is we need
to listen for changes on that,
because we're not capturing it
at the moment.
We need to add those
products to the cart itself.
So what Filip is
doing now-- he's
getting access to the
stream, he's listening to it.
And then, the product will
be the event coming in,
and all we need to
do at this point,
then, is add that
product to the cart.
Great.
So now we have state managed.
The other thing we
need to do is make sure
that itemCount is always
updated when products are added.
And all we need to do
there is do what we did,
but in the opposite direction--
is to add the itemCount
to the itemCount stream.
And we're done?
FILIP HRACEK: Yep, we're done.
Back to you the slides, please.
So, as you could see, we were
able to implement this business
logic component pretty quickly.
It is a little more
complicated, but it gives you
a lot of cool stuff.
First of all, it is really
just steams in, streams out.
Whatever happens
in the component,
you don't care about--
as a Flutter UI.
Then, we could add more
things to this bloc.
So we could add a
stream of total cost.
Whenever the cost
of the cart changes,
you probably want to update
your user to give it that.
And then, you have a stream
of lists of cart items, which
is the items that you
want to always update
whenever you add something to
the cart, or remove from it.
So that is cool.
And, again, these are
different aspects of our model
that we want to show.
Now, I have a problem
with one part of this,
and that is this part.
We're streaming the total cost
as integers, which makes sense
internally in the component--
it is a numerical
value, after all.
But what it leads to is code
in your views like this.
You have to somehow convert,
or format, the numerical value
to some kind of string.
Which is, if you think
about it, business logic--
this shouldn't be in views.
So you can go back
to your CartBloc,
and you can just change
this to a stream of string
that is already formatted.
So whenever you want to
show your total cost,
you just stream
the formatted one.
And so you just reuse that
same business logic that
is inside the component now.
That gives you another
very cool thing,
and that is that if
you add a new thing,
or new input to the model--
sorry, to the component--
for example, Sink of Locale.
So users, now, can change
anywhere in your app
from a US shop to an EU shop.
Now, you can pipe this change
as a stream to the total cost.
And so, internally,
in the bloc, you
will update the
total costs string,
even though maybe the numerical
value is still the same.
And that means that
anywhere in the app
that the user changes
this, you don't
need to think about
it as a developer.
It will always update
anywhere else--
the total cost.
This would be a real pain
to implement any other way.
So we have this nice
flow of data and events.
We have widgets that
are only listening
to what they need to know.
And we're using good
old StreamBuilders
to make that work.
MATT SULLIVAN: So let's take
a look at what we have now.
Accessing state
in Fillips example
was solved by using
the InheritedWidget
pattern to pass access to
the bloc down the tree.
We now have very fine
updating on change,
because we have
different aspects
of our data being represented
by different streams.
And those widgets
subscribing to those screams
will only rebuild when those
aspects of data changes.
And, finally, we now
have the converse--
we have mutating state
by pumping data--
or requests to mutate state--
into our business
logic, where we're
observing for change, and
then we can update it there.
There's this nice pattern of
pushing data in via streams,
and then updating via streams,
which we think is very elegant.
This is great, but
you all have options.
SetState() works fine if you
have a very shallow tree,
and your app is fairly simple.
ScopedModel is a fantastic
way for a model, which
is relatively straightforward,
to be passed up and down,
and change on a tree
of arbitrary depth.
For those of you who
like the redux pattern,
there is an excellent
redux implementation built
by the community-- the
redux package for Dart,
and Flutter Redux
for Flutter, which
will give you that pattern,
and you can use that as well.
But if there's one
thing that we'd
like you to take
away from this, it's
that Flutter's widgets, in
combination with streams,
gives you a very reactive way
to not only handle your UI,
but handle the flow of
data through your app,
and handle the updating of
your UI when that data changes.
So we highly recommend
you go and check
out Dart Streams, and the rxdart
as an option for building state
in your apps.
We'd love to hear from you.
Please go to the site,
and give us some feedback.
All of the code
you've seen today
is in Fillips GitHub account.
I did some pull
requests-- honestly,
he didn't write everything.
And not only do we show
you the code we showed,
but we have a redux
implementation
and a couple of others there
as well for you to check out.
I want to give a shout
out to the cookbook
that us and the community
have been working on.
There's some wonderful
patterns in there--
everything from widget
creation, to network, to JSON.
It's a great place to go.
And there were two
other talks that
have happened prior to this.
Fortunately, we have a time
machine called YouTube,
so you can go back in time.
And if you want to learn
about building beautiful UIs,
or building apps end-to-end, I
would recommend you check those
out-- those are good talks.
And I would like to say
thank you for your time.
FILIP HRACEK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]